you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with lung cancer this
video will help you understand how to
manage
it your lungs are a pair of organs
inside your chest that allow you to
breathe
lung cancer is a disease in which cancer
cells form in your lung tissue
treatment for lung cancer may remove or
destroy the cancer
after treatment it's very important to
have a follow-up care plan
this includes going to follow-up
appointments
your doctor will want to make sure the
cancer has not returned and check for
health problems resulting from treatment
it's also important to get regular ct
scans to check for cancer
if you are on any medications continue
to take them as prescribed by your
doctor
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
if you had lung surgery or other
treatments follow any instructions you
are given
you may also need to make some of the
following healthy lifestyle changes
if you smoke it's important to quit
smoking
this lowers the risk for cancer
returning or spreading
eat a healthy diet with more fruits
vegetables and whole grains this will
help you stay strong and feel better
limit how much alcohol you drink
it can reduce your risk of cancer
become physically active
activities like walking riding a bicycle
or swimming can help you feel better and
less tired
talk to your doctor before starting an
exercise routine
knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming
you may have worries about things like
your condition and how it affects your
family
treatments and hospital stays medical
bills
and your job
fortunately there are ways to cope with
this
remember that your doctor and health
care team are there to answer any
questions you have
the following sources of support can
help you cope with your concerns
social workers
church leaders
counselors
and support groups
talk to your doctor if you have any
questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage lung cancer
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you